[Music]
and it was supposed to be fake news oh
you say right I got it I know what to do
with this article when I hear article
names
I wasn't gonna say why it was no it was
just the title I get used to it is
everything I'm gonna say it orgasmic
point so far so they're winning maybe
the way you deliver it up submitted by
me Neil there's a wet duck that's good
Winona Ryder's claiming that she
actually married
Keanu Reeves instead of the 1992 movie
Dracula I believe it what I hundred
percent believe what they had a they had
an actual wedding while filming I know
what happened I never gonna watch that
movie no no writer is the honeymoon over
lettuce she's the Dean oh no writer
did you watch strangers really just like
she did stranger thing I know the name I
just don't remember how mister mister
deeds with Adam Sandler oh yeah I did
yeah yeah yeah that's the girl that
supported that that was a reporter
trying to trick him yeah and they go to
her town she's the one that always
talked to you
whistle between that's so sad she's dead
she says so many great things and we
want to remember for mr. deeds no but
yes so they came out in a movie together
in 1992 and there was this wedding scene
and the director did use a real priest
to officiate the wedding so they made
the entire thing so Winona so right now
they're about to come out in their
fourth movie together Keanu Reeves and
went on the writer and so they were
doing this interview and that's when she
was like you know I think we're married
in real life like I really think we are
cuz it was like the real deal in the
real church like the real preacher just
[ __ ] off do they sign papers yeah you
have to sign papers so what are you
gonna do sign papers what is marriage
right right
is anything real it's all the value that
we place on it we gotta tell that to
[ __ ] tin and Chia right now dude [ __ ]
did you have us dude this whole time
it's not real 10 that was shortest
wedding I've been to oh for sure that's
dope I like yeah it was like 15 missiles
like that's it
cuz Indian weddings are 17 days long
whole hundred percent and this was like
doubt that's it I want to go to annual
wedding what do they say for 17 days
it's just everyday than you think it's
actually five days long okay but it's
like every day's a new event so you
thing new clothes you have to have five
six different outfits every day and I
was like I don't have to wear one thing
also guys and girls there's my first
non-indian wedding event so even the
guests wear a bunch of different clothes
- yeah oh you have because it's fine you
don't want to show up yeah come on now
more news one day and then the reception
is the next day and then you have like
the ladies sing Keith which is like the
all ladies saying and then you have like
wow the day where you like clean the guy
and you give him like a little like
tumeric and then you have another day
it's like yeah in front of everybody
they just rub you all your relatives rub
you with turmeric well I thought you
meant like a bath bath like you're in a
bath tub and then they pour two more to
scrub you with tumeric oh you know what
his culture does um the guys why are you
sorry
Chinese can we do an Indian wedding
let's redo our wedding that sounds
that's just expensive as [ __ ] man
it's expensive as funny
but yet the groom has to go over to the
to the right yeah the bride's house and
you you lie computer know you're trying
to steal her and all her bridesmaids are
like no and then you eventually get her
when you give her money and then after
that all that happy ceremony thing I
think I bail vaguely remember that but I
haven't I've never been instilled with
these traditions okay I don't know well
I'm glad I taught you something that's
actually have a video series we're
talking about this whole thing can they
watch that section check it out it's on
my channel youtube.com slash true 5 days
so when people have average high vision
when you have like a couple of any
weddings to go to like during the whole
year then you have a ton of vacation
who's ever prioritize Oh which one's
more boring like if you're not like
immediate relatives of the family then
you'll come to like ceremony usually
more intimate like less people know
there's a pic of thousand people so
thousands of people are using this
wedding and I was like this is it so
there's a ton of people force for six
days straight
just spit out I'm like this is it Tim no
just like no this is interesting
no literally like 200 people for any
people just invite people just because
they're like oh this person's gonna get
mad if you don't find like even people
really care about what other Indian
people thinking we've just form our
whole lives yeah around what other
people think like nobody really truly
lives yeah yeah I mean that's
collectivist society man your parents
like you have to be this thing that we
tell you to because we have to do it
whatever every occasion style - right
right it's gonna think about so it's
like you have to invite every single
person but you could just hate like how
do people that come to your wedding you
don't even talk to / you can't stand
yeah invite them just because it's
formality it's like part of culture oh
thank God that we just threw away those
family values man [ __ ]
nation wedding this is easier that's why
people do destination weddings I'm so
like it's a runaway really care about us
we'll pay for it let me let don't really
care or not you meet them out so they
wait themselves up alright so I'm going
to show you guys the clip from the movie
when they got married Catholic wedding
you can have one well I'm not Catholic
you can I like the singing look how
young is I know their books oh yeah very
handsome people I didn't know was Keanu
Reeves that was Keanu Reeves yeah I
forgot he's a handsome what I'm noticing
recently is like I watched a lot of
movies growing up right and I haven't
watched it again as an adult or even
like in my in my 20s so I remember like
blur like I know scenes of it but I'm
like oh [ __ ] that actor was here so that
movie looks familiar to you but you just
don't remember it yeah I don't remember
I don't even seen that movie never
matrix is all you need to know did Keanu
everything else trash you guys ever see
like old movies and then you you see you
like a star today that was like a side
character like some extra and you're
like holy [ __ ] were like like that like
Jonah Hill was sucking on a titty for
the whole movie for grandmas boy oh yeah
what he was such a side character yeah
yeah when you watch it some movies again
you're just normal
yeah no it's uh if I think it's his crew
Adam Tanner's not in it but it's like
you know like he always brings this
homey happy Madison yeah yeah those guys
so it's like it's a movie starring yeah
one of them the whole role is him just
sucking on a tee yeah I think they have
parties and then they just grandma no no
no there's like a hot girl like in the
house party okay
they grow and I was like oh my godness
Joni Jonah Hill but that's all he did he
just sits there and he literally just
sucks on titties how old was he he was
young but he I mean you could tell it's
clearly him 12 no it was like maybe a
couple years young was that like you
really really really fat Jonah help or
regular fat Jonah it was still fat Jonah
Hill and it wasn't like no there was one
word when he first started coming on the
scene I think he was like like morbidly
obese like super sad he was pretty he
was bigger than that there was there was
there was a movie where I remember him
he cracked me the [ __ ] up because there
was scene where he got scared he
screamed like a [ __ ] girl and
everybody was dying in a theater but he
was so huge then he was bigger than Matt
oh hey big but I was like one of his
like breakout films too because when he
was playing like one of the lead roles I
don't like the three but it was about
these guys who created their own college
because they didn't get into accepted
into college together
Ultimo no definitely no okay no I never
seen them is she going crazy crazy yeah
why because she thinks she's married or
was it like a joke like oh actually no
you think about it we might be married
or she like we're married I want half no
it's more it's more like the like the
realization of like I think we're
married like for real in real life but
so the director even agreed with her to
we're like they might be married in real
life got a sort through like state
papers and see if it really went through
or something they go to Vegas and get a
divorce to go to make well do they sign
papers yeah that's what I'm wondering or
do they have to call God and be like
listen I think it's because it was just
by word right like it's like having a
ceremony with witnesses so then that
kind of like has a contradict in the old
school days before even paperwork
existed and they were just
together and a priest would marry them I
think that's the kind of Larry yeah yeah
witnesses and then you have an actual
ordained or like what do you call it
officiated or no no they're married in
the 1600s yeah yeah it was a Romanian
priests Catholic weddings are the most
boring things on they totally are Matt
shoot my really is they take forever
it's like to a horror my face when I
said two hours that's amore ceremony
itself is like four or five hours it's
so there's four or five hours of talking
like apologize everybody just watch
because I know I'm gonna get slack
they're so boring because sometimes
people are just like yeah there's music
involved right and we'll get like the
most like just the boring musicians
involved to play the hems and stuff so
you have to sit there and I'm falling
asleep I'm fine see just like this just
just so like people don't see that I'm
flying asleep cuz like you have to sit
cross-legged on the ground so I'm just
like I just like that's on the ground to
you oh don't your legs fall asleep
everything falls yeah there's like
there's a preset officiates first you
listen to him and then the Brian the
groom sit there and ever there's more
hams and the bridge is sitting then
there's even more hams and every sitting
and then finally they play like the
wedding hams and then they get up and
then they walk around like our holy book
for fun anybody have fun at the wedding
like is everyone falls receptionist 101
gets drunk but like the actual wedding
is in the temple so no drinking no
everything serious like no one's having
fun it's never fun it's part of like
it's like I have to do this I think the
only fun part is when the bride walks in
cuz you're like oh that's what she looks
like and then after that you're like
damn either gonna be a minute born do
that walk too by the way is [ __ ] slow
that's who you've seen it I've been a
part of 200 yeah so you know yeah it's
very slow cuz that Camaro has a whole
bunch of like ooh can I get a
demonstration do you want is are you
walking slow
how to walk around this table in like
two or three minutes yeah once are you
walking like a little snake like you're
walking like there's like a scabbard too
is pretty dope though Wow if sloth speed
oh I think I used to walk like that my
mom's like my mom's Buddhist so my mom's
Buddhist and then and part of the
Buddhist uh like in like the ceremonies
or whatever like after you pray and you
read like the book then you chant right
and you're going through like like all
the I guess the Buddhist pews like yeah
like a little snake and Newark oh the
shape of a snake I was thinking like so
this is like this is a Chinese version
of Buddhism where you're like walking
like this and you walk like this speed
yeah that's it that's exactly what it is
pretty fast you know what the [ __ ] that
thing is good especially because this is
the type of things that the floor is
[ __ ] comfortable [ __ ] yeah is it
heated
it's like tempur-pedic yeah I fell
asleep so [ __ ] fast
I started snoring in my [ __ ] friend
hit me huh oh he hit me like stop oh
they were cousins carpeted and just nice
and plush or kneeling you get to chill
on a tempurpedic bed dude it's [ __ ]
like a jujitsu mat yeah
[Music]